take me back to the pressure of the
first time so David Lee Roth is out of
the band Samy says to his wife at the
time hey David Lee Roth's no longer in
Van Halen those guys are going to call
me he was so confident that you guys
were going to call him right right Sammy
I mean you knew yeah I just felt it it
just came right out of my mouth just
like a lyric you know just what was the
call like I mean Eddie called you
directly and said hey Sammy would you
come and jam with us cuz we we know we
don't have a lead singer was that
basically it that was basically it it
was like he was at all of our car
mechanic clao on police place he saw my
Ferrari that was there getting a tuneup
while I was on tour I got home from tour
and he sees my car and he's claudo says
that's Sammy Hagar's car you should call
him he said you have his number he said
yeah he sat down on the phone right
claudo shop and Eddie was so humble back
then he was such a sweet humble human
being and and he's just going oh man why
don't you just come on down you know I
say oh Ed man I I'd love to come
and play with you but I just got home
from tour I just cut my hair off and I'm
I'm taking a big break and he's going ah
you know I said when you know how about
in a couple weeks or something he's go
no no like how about tomorrow I started
saying I like this guy you know I'd met
him a couple times he was just such a
sweet human being I was sitting in the
control room at 5150 Studio when Sammy
comes walking in and I'm expecting to
see this guy with long curly hair you
know comes rolling in he comes in no
hair it's all shaved off I'm like wa
what wait is this started over again had
to start over you know and uh you know
the funny thing about it because Eddie
Alex and myself had been working on some
material which was going to eventually
end up on that first uh record with
Sammy
5150 and uh Sammy came in and we started
one of them was good enough and the
other song was summer nights so we go
out and we're g you know we put the
cassette tape in and we're going to go
jam and just you know just have some fun
he starts singing what did we do first
summer nights or good enough well I
think it's good enough but but summer
nights when did that when I just started
singing radio Sammy start I mean he sang
the actual lyric that ended up in the
song Ned played I think it it was good
enough first you know and and we can
play a little piece of that if you want
and it was like we go hello
[Music]
be woo
wow
you great not
guaranteed GRE it up and turn
on you got to throw it down and roll it
over once maybe twice and Sh down down
down
down which is good enough good enough
to I can't get enough I can't get
[Music]
enough she good to love
me I'm working up an
appeti she like a hard work all my body
needs I like to open up little six on a
half
shell it's
woo this she's good enough good enough
to I Can't Get Enough can't get
[Music]
enough she's good
enough good
[Music]
enough
good come on now
right morning holy cow wow wow can you
imagine wait beautiful job on that with
the woo I mean that shit's hard to play
a't it I mean come
on